throw to have here on the first time on
the show i loved his work in the nick
man you know what i felt about the nick
that show
should never have been canceled we
should be seeing season 19 of it years
from now
um and uh he plays the role of toby
damon on this is us and he's here to
talk about
the debut album uh of joseph the spouse
debut album six feet from under is
available now wherever you get your
music the actor chris sullivan here on
the rich house show how are you chris
hey thanks man i'm doing well thanks for
uh being a fan of the knicks
oh that is one of the greatest shows in
the history of television chris
period and the story and you're i
honestly
now that i'm hearing your voice after
obviously i hear your voice on this is
us
uh how does a kid from palm springs nail
the accent of
someone from uh from ireland uh like you
did you know
how'd you nail that uh you know when i
was
18 or 19 getting started in acting i
realized i'm a six foot four
uh man of irish descent at some point i
am going to be called upon
to to uh fulfill my destiny and
so i just started practicing early and
and picking up a lot of different
regions and
and then by the time stephen soderbergh
came calling i was ready to go
what was it like working with him chris
you know he's he's an incredibly unique
uh artist he for those who don't know
stephen soderbergh is a director
who also operates his own camera
and also edits all of his own footage
and so what you end up with is a
singular
vision and it makes for a really focused
really high intensity fast moving
but calm set it's it's a very
interesting
uh place to work nobody else works like
him so it was a it was a real treat
what do you mean calm what do you mean
by that chris
like he just he's just sure he just
knows
what he needs because he's operating the
camera and he's editing
so he there's no extra filler we're not
we're not shooting things on the off
chance that he might use them
so he just shows up he knows exactly
what he wants
he tells you what he wants and as soon
as he gets it he moves on and there's
not really a lot of like
uh second guessing himself but it's some
it's i've never seen anything like it
and it's it was amazing it was a couple
of seasons
um and i think the the uh seasons that
were being planned
but then eventually scrapped was to take
the nick the hospital from
you know the late uh 1800s early 19
uh 20th century um and put it in the
future
i i mean it was about to be it's about
to really get interesting
you know yeah i think there's there's a
couple of people who are who are
threatening to uh to bring it back so
let's see what happens
ah are you dropping a little is that was
that a breadcrumb i just heard drop on
the floor there chris
that's a breadcrumb for me too i i hear
these things from the internet
okay fantastic wait and see what happens
okay
so uh a kid from palm springs california
do you have a sports team that you
you follow any any sports that uh
interest you chris
you know i i was born in palm springs
but my my dad's work
took us up to sacramento in 1986.
okay so that was right in the sweet spot
for your joe montana steve young
49er years and and we i think we arrived
right as you know the bash brothers uh
were playing for the a's uh the giants
were big back then so it was a
it was a good uh it was a good
kind of period for for a kid to be in uh
central california
so you chris sullivan uh have been to
candlestick
back in the day did you go to some games
at the stick
yeah absolutely oh my gosh absolutely
the
one of those those those ballparks that
are that are situated
you know in neighboring i mean
technically that's a neighborhood it was
well i mean if anybody ever tried to get
out of candlestick they'd know
uh that's a that was the neighborhood oh
yeah you were in it
that's burlingame man i mean that was it
oh yes
it had the the same kind of special vibe
you know i spent uh
my acting career started in chicago so
that same special vibe that wrigley
wrigley field has you know especially
especially for for an actor with uh very
little money to show up you know
sixth inning and get a ten dollar ticket
and and walk into wrigley field
you know whatever afternoon
i mean wrigley field chris looked like a
movie it still does looks like a movie
set like the old
like the old uh movie blazing saddles
where they created a fake rock ridge it
looks like it's a set like you could
just shove it right over
you know it really is amazing it's a
special spot
no doubt chris sullivan here on the rich
eisen show okay so
um music sir um this is your your debut
album
six feet from under but you're it's not
you're you're not chris sullivan you're
you're joseph the spouse
right that's what you got right here
yeah yeah i took on a took on a bit of a
character
um to uh to deliver the music through
okay and it felt kind of right as an
actor so yeah
kind of a a uh a moniker
to to perform under to kind of create a
bit of distance between
myself and and the music um
okay so who is joseph the spouse who is
joseph the spouse well
chris you know joseph i i was in
i was in a an eastern mass a couple
years ago okay not catholic but i went
with a couple of family members and they
started rattling off
saints and they started naming all the
ones you've heard of
and then they got to some more you know
kind of
lesser known saints and all of a sudden
the the priest said joseph the spouse
and it's joseph of the joseph and mary
story
and i just had kind of started thinking
about you know this
this this character in literature who's
really only claimed to fame as being the
witness to this miracle and i feel the
same way
when i'm playing music and when i get
the opportunity to collaborate with
other artists
it feels like i'm witnessing a miracle
like some like something is appearing
from nothing
and so the name just kind of stuck and
we decided to run with it okay
six feet from under i can kind of guess
what that that uh
that's that's intimating right here
still breathing
okay there you go available now wherever
you get your music
um also still breathing quite a bit is
uh the hit show this is us what's it
like being on a hit show like this chris
sullivan you play the role of toby damon
in this
this program and um you're already
renewed for season six currently in
season five right now
what's that we you know it's it's it's a
special thing to be to be a part of
um especially in these times where where
people are looking for things
to um to bring them together
or to give them some kind of uh
hope i feel like our show is a very
hopeful
um kind of the the writers and dan
bogama kind of created this
this guidebook for relationships and
guidebook for living
um and so it's it's nice we got it we
have a great
great fan base and and
we've been we've been very lucky to be
able to tell these stories
do you do yeah is everyone have like a
good cry during the table read i mean
is that uh how it seems like that might
happen
every now and then we got to save those
tears for when the camera's rolling
don't
i don't know it's just you can get into
it you know what i mean oh yeah it's no
absolutely the scripts the scripts are
are
extremely impactful on all of us but
there's something about
you know i can shoot i can shoot all day
long and then go back and and when the
episode airs and
and after the editors have gotten their
magic hands on it and
our composer sid cosla has added the
music you know there's some there's some
alchemy there
that for as as
special and as heavy as the set can be
um once they add that music and
and yeah and all the post-production
touches it certainly takes it to a new
level i find myself
crying more more watching the show
it's amazing and we've had justin
hartley here and you know i know he
benches a lot or he can squat a lot but
if you get in a ram you're 6'4 you could
take him right when it all comes down to
it
not to stir it up yeah just by just by
sheer weight
you know i i he he he is definitely his
his uh abilities in the gym far
outweigh mine but i think i'm in a i
think i'm in a different weight class
okay i don't know i don't know how you
would uh i think i've got him by
by 30 pounds okay which unfortunately
isn't me bragging no
no no no no but hey look every every
every lb counts
um and and you could take him in tennis
though right i'm told you're that's how
you grew up right chris you could take
him in tennis though
when it comes down absolutely yeah i
know i could definitely take him in
tennis i i
i grew up playing competitive junior
tennis and uh
went to uh loyola marymount on a
scholarship before i
before i gave up the court for the stage
that's so what is
what is somebody six for i mean were you
like what are they i'll i'm gonna date
myself like the rosco
tanner of of uh oh yeah tennis
i mean how fast was your service no i
how fast was your sister
what you could talk about if i was ever
clocked
on a gun was 155. come on
chris you're serving promise you buck
55 you chris sullivan have served a ball
a buck 55 really listen i used to love
going to play
in in reno because playing tennis at
altitude
the ball moves even faster
so i i was able to serve 155 at sea
level
uh once or twice my service my servant
volley game was certainly
something to be reckoned with but at
that uh at six foot five
the um the uh the agility
is it's not there it's less than so yeah
you know yeah the uh the professional uh
tour record is 157 so you're you're
right
so i assume your serve was not returned
the buck 55 did not come back over the
night that was an ace right
yes most most often if i was able to if
i was able to uh
to get and get in the groove the uh that
my service game was my
my biggest weapon who did you beat did
you beat anybody that turned pro
you got like a pelt on the wall chris
i don't have any pelts on the wall i i
certainly um
i certainly i played i played junior
tennis i
think i was ranked uh you know in the
mid 30s
throughout my junior career here in
california
which uh which tennis is one of those
games where
the distance between let's say the top
five players in the world and five
through ten
it seems it seems like like a huge chasm
and the further down you go the the
distance just gets bigger and bigger and
bigger but it's a
as i as i learned you know the the the
mental game
is is where tennis is at yes and the
kind of uh the mental i want to say
uh for lack of a better word the mental
instability that serves a uh
an actor yes it doesn't help a tennis
player
i love it so if we had uh uh this is us
tennis tournament you're the top seed
essentially is what you're saying yes
sir i think i can confidently say that
okay the time
i didn't i never thought of your your
outstanding program uh
through possibly of a bracket or a
tournament or anything like that but
here we are i appreciate the call chris
thank you very much congrats again on
your debut album joseph the spouse debut
album six feet from under available
right now
where you get your music and of course
this is us season six renewed already
it's gonna return in january everybody
looking forward to that and thanks again
for your work in the nick i love that
show man
my pleasure thanks for talking you got
it right back at you that's chris
sullivan follow him on twitter at
sullivan tweet and on instagram with his
near half
million following at sullivan grams
and of course you can catch it right
here on peacock this is us watch it
stream it
when we're not on obviously you know
obviously after we're over
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here